good afternoon dear love life
good afternoon and welcome to this
webinar organized by the ftth council
Europe
I'm Vincent Garnier the director general
of the council and with me I have the
pleasure to welcome Bruno Felton
Consulting Ben why is the main speaker
for for the event today I will just
start with a few housekeeping item and
introduction before I give the floor to
Benoit we we have a great Tech up for
for this session
um so I I guess the introduction will
give some time for the rest of the
audience to join us but yes benue if you
could bring us to the next slide I will
say as an introduction a few words about
the ftth council
we are an industry Association
non-profit organization with the
objective to promote full fiber Network
as the most future-proof and sustainable
Access Network Technology
our activity is around a publishing
report educating the entire ecosystem
influencing policy makers and also
organizing events some of them physical
like the ftth conference which will take
place very soon in Madrid where the
entire industry can meet Network
if you bring us to the next slide Benoit
I will just explain that this event is
part of a series of webinar we're
organizing uh mostly more or less on a
week on a monthly basis
and we try to offer to our audience
um you know best insights about
technology about Market drivers
and these are
promoted as thought
um
thought leadership content
a few practical information on the next
slide this webinar will be recorded So
the replay is accessible and will be
sent to to all registrants after this
session together with the link to the
main asset that we are describing today
in billuar's presentation if you want to
ask question please use the question box
that you will see on your on your
control panel
um you you can type the question we will
uh we'll have we have reserved time at
the end of this webinar for Benward to
address any any of your question if we
cannot cover all of them we will
certainly follow up after this session
so with that
um I have a pleasure to officially
welcome again bernward Felton director
at plume Consulting and just to give you
a brief overview of what you can expect
from this webinar at the ftth council
we're monitoring the evolution of ftth
rollout throughout Europe we see that
now we have passed the 50 threshold in
term of coverage
but at the same time we also noticed
that the tech up is still around 50
percent which means that although one in
one in two household in Europe has
potentially access to fiber only a
quarter of the population is effectively
connected to the internet on the basis
of full fiber Networks
understanding the dynamic the driver and
the hurdles around the tech up and how
demand can be better
increased is really the objective of the
study that we have asked Plum to to
undertake so with that I will leave the
floor to Benoit who will re-explain the
content of the study and deliver the key
takeaway from that very important work
thank you vanson
um hello everyone
um I will just very briefly tell you who
I am and uh and who Plum Consulting is
before uh going straight into the the
content so
um
I'm Benoit Felton I've been working in
uh favorite to the home related topics
for uh close to two decades now
um and
um I have joined last year Plum
consulting which is a
boutique consulting firm uh based in
London in Paris
uh our key Focus areas uh revolve around
the economics of network infrastructure
um radio spectrum and it's its economic
value and Technical efficiencies uh more
and more we work around digital
platforms the ecosystem the value chain
of digital platforms and their impact on
regulation
and of course there are a lot of other
topics but I think that covers the main
things that you might be interested in
um today
uh indeed when uh we were initially
contacted and commissioned by the
council to do this study we first looked
at
uh what we would call the potential for
subscriber growth
in the Fabrics of home arena in Europe
clearly uh the shift to vhcn in European
policy has had a very strong and
measurable impact on deployment but the
fact is that take up hasn't always
followed suit
and right now take up at a European
scale is around 50 percent of homes
passed which brings it around 25 a
little above 25 percent
of
um potential subscribers
um so that means that half of that could
be addressed today with existing already
deployed Networks
and twice that could be addressed
through further deployments
so it was important for us to understand
um
what drove take up and what could be
done to accelerate that growth
so the study was structured
uh into full streams of work that were
consecutive and
um
one of the key objectives in the early
phases was to try and understand
why certain countries had equivalent
level of deployment had much better take
up than others or to put it another way
why some countries were lagging behind
so what we did for this was first of all
we did a high level quantitative
analysis across the entire EU footprint
plus UK
and we tried to identify key drivers for
a fiber adoption
then as a second phase we drilled down
into eight specific countries
that we felt highlighted particularly
interesting drivers or hurdles
we also analyzed existing demand side
policies there are not that many in
Europe but we felt it was necessary to
look into how effective they had been
and on the basis of all of this we made
some conclusions and recommendations on
what policies could be that could make a
difference
before we start to describe the results
we felt it would be interesting to have
some feedback from you the audience on
how important you think
this issue of adoption is
um so we have a little poll that's going
to show up on your side
um please answer the poll
um it'll take a minute and then we can
briefly discuss
um the results
yeah thank you
while I see that many
of a 10 of our attendees are voting uh
we give everyone a few seconds so for
option from your industry perspective
how much of an issue is adoption of ftdh
not an issue at all a minor issue a
major issue or a vital issue that could
endanger the industry
so there seems to be now a clear
profile which which is being defined I
give maybe three four seconds before we
share the results
um yeah I think we can go live now it
will not change too much
so let me share the the result not issue
at all eight percent a minor issue 17
percent
a major issue the vast majority of the
audience 61 and 14 think this is a vital
issue so maybe a few reaction a few
comments from your side Benoit before we
move to the rest of your deck well I
mean this means that
basically 75 of people who are with us
today think this is a very important
issue uh and we think so too and this
kind of
um validates or justifies the fact that
we've uh spent this this uh time and
effort to to find some answers to this
so let me now delve into what these
answers
um
might be
so I'm not going to go in a great level
of depth here this is more for future
reference but essentially we analyzed uh
three types of
data points at EU plus UK level uh
social economic factors such as income
levels income distribution poverty rates
GDP Etc digital Supply factors Broadband
prices quality of existing copper
networks Broadband speeds
and digital demand factors such as
digital literacy consumer equipment
ownership and Broadband usage levels the
constraint that we had was that we had
to have data that was consistent across
the entire footprint and we also had to
have data that was publicly available so
there are a few indicators that we
wished we could have found but we
weren't able to find but nonetheless
this Led Led us to a number of uh really
interesting
conclusions
so the first one is that there clearly
seems to be a symbiotic relationship
between the speed of deployment and the
speed of take-up
um the kind of
um common common thinking about this uh
is that deployment drives take up
because obviously if you don't deploy
you cannot have adoption but looking at
the data we felt that the causality was
a little more a little harder to
establish and
um
it is likely that in some instances
a high initial take up on an initial
deployment actually accelerates
further deployment because it becomes
easier for uh for Network operators to
find funding uh they also
generate more cash flow much faster so
really it's both of these are fading
into each other and there seems to be a
kind of virtuous circle that once it's
in motion actually really boosts
um adoption
the second aspect which is not a
surprise but it's I think important to
have it kind of restated is that the
price gap between fiber to the home
prices and Legacy Broadband prices uh
particularly ADSL and fdtc
that price Gap can be a hurdle if it's
too important so clearly the higher that
price Gap and the lower
the take-up
uh again not surprising price
sensitivity but it's important to
reiterate because it means that
anyone who is
in the business of selling their
deployed fiber needs to take that into
account
um
another hurdle which is not so prevalent
but is still
worth thinking about and worth
mentioning
is that if there is a high price
difference between fiber to home and
mobile broadband that seems to be a
hurdle as well so in other words a high
price difference between fiber to home
and mobile broadband likely drives some
customers to prefer mobile broadband and
basically
disregard fixed Broadband entirely
um so that's worth keeping in mind
and finally
an interesting finding in the sense that
we didn't find anything
is that we didn't find any strong
correlation between socioeconomic
indicators and fiber adoption in other
words
you know things like income levels and
uh income distribution rural versus
Urban population this kind of thing did
not seem to have a measurable impact on
take-up one particular aspect here which
did surprise us but we think now that we
kind of understand why that is the case
um is that we couldn't find a
correlation between digital literacy and
fiber to home adoption and we think that
the reason for this is that if there is
a correlation it's a correlation between
Broadband in general and digital
literacy uh but there is no indication
that an increase in digital literacy
would immediately boost fiber as opposed
to any other access means to the
internet or or Broadband in general
so
that was the kind of information that we
could gather from this high level macro
analysis clearly this didn't go deep
enough uh for our expectations and we
decided to do a more qualitative
analysis on eight countries
um
some countries where we knew the take-up
was very high compared to the average
some countries where we knew that it was
lower than average and the idea was to
try and understand
uh the reasons for all of this so the
the countries that we uh that we looked
at
were Denmark France Germany Italy Poland
Spain Sweden and the UK
uh and this has allowed us to identify a
set of drivers and hurdles and build a
conceptual framework which I am going to
share with you in a minute uh some of
these drivers and hurdles are in the
hands of the market and the market
players in other words
um it is things that the market players
need to do to accelerate adoption others
are in the hands of policy makers and
governments
um so this lead us leads us to a second
poll question that we wanted to share
with you before we uh before we move on
um
which is more about where do you think
the
um the
bonus of uh uh improving take up might
lie
yeah and the the question indeed is
which of the following do you think is
the number one reason to explain ftth
adoption issue where there exists so
four answers a service provider not
doing a good job
the government non-implementing policies
to facilitate adoption the third option
is consumer who don't want ftth
and the final one is the Reliance of
mobile which makes fixed Broadband less
attractive so service provider
government consumer or mobile being the
main reason for difficulty uh around
ftth adoption so I'm giving a few
seconds for
Origins to vote this is much more
balanced than what we had in the
previous question I must tell you Benoit
so I might give another a few seconds to
make sure that we capture
accurately the the sentiment from
from our audience today I'll close the
poll
um and share and actually we see 32
percent thinking that service provider
somehow are to blame for that government
follows closely with 26 percent
uh eighteen percent of the audience
thinks that the main reason comes from
consumer not wanting ftth and 24 uh that
the mobile
aspect uh is is really impacting that uh
that element of adoption
so quite balanced uh between those four
um possibilities
so I think what's interesting here is
that
um this actually gels in with some of
the findings that we're going to share
um one might say that to a certain
extent consumers not wanting ftth and
and mobile are still Market elements in
the sense that
um you know it's up to service providers
to convince consumers that they need
ftth and it's also up to them to be able
to compete effectively with with mobile
um but that's still uh that still leaves
a quarter of respondents who think that
government policy could make a
difference we happen to think that
um it's maybe a bit more
um of a strong lever than that but I
will share the results of the second
phase of the study now so we can
highlight this
all right so this is the conceptual
framework that we built
the idea here
uh was to basically capture all of the
main hurdles and drivers but also to
allocate them to either the market or
the policy makers uh I'm not going to go
through all of these in great depth and
and in the study you will see that this
conceptual framework is applied to all
eight countries so you can really see
um in each country which uh hurdles and
drivers have been uh key in in getting
the market to where it is today but I'm
going to talk about kind of groupings of
these uh more
more generally so the first hurdles that
we see on the market side is the whole
aspect of actually connecting
um the customer to the network so this
takes essentially two
um two sides one side is related to the
physical uh connection of the network uh
in a lot of markets especially in
markets where
um there's a lot of uh single home
ownership
there is some resistance to people
coming in drilling through your wall Etc
um it really depends on what the the
nature of the real estate is uh and some
countries have kind of addressed this
preemptively uh others are really
struggling with this and the second one
of course is that sometimes service
providers charge for connection and uh
that also creates a lot of resistance of
course there are costs to connecting a
new customer so uh sometimes this is
more Insidious so even if the end user
doesn't have to pay
um to connect well the service providers
have to so for example
um as an illustration of the first point
the UK is a market where uh there's a
lot of challenge around getting into the
homes a lot of resistance
Italy is a country where switching fees
have been a problem because the
wholesale service providers that are on
uh on Telecom Italia's Network for fttc
are reluctant to pay switching fees
um to get onto open fibers ftth Network
um even though this would be transparent
from the customer's point of view but
just having to replace a CPE is a form
of switching fee
um the second uh category of of hurdles
and drivers are related to uh two things
the first is really the the policy and
Industry choices that were made 10 years
ago uh when it comes to uh whether to go
down the fiber to the cabinet route or
to go down the fiber to the Home Route
um are kind of Haunting the markets that
went for fttc because
um it is much harder for service
providers
um to differentiate an ftth offer when
fttc delivers decent Broadband
um it is much easier to do that in
markets where the alternative is is ADSL
because the Gap is so much wider so so
this is something we see in Germany in
the UK in Italy and to a certain extent
in Denmark
um the Legacy technology choices or
networks are creating a kind of slowed
down
um of take-up and even in Denmark where
the hiccup is quite High we see that in
urban areas where cable is present to
take up is much lower
um content availability now this one is
is tricky because first of all it may be
going away to a certain extent so we
think that it still is important in a
few markets but it clearly is less
important than it was a few years ago
basically this is about who owns gated
content
um but as more and more of the content
especially video content moves to
um online you know universally
accessible
uh uh subscriptions this is starting to
disappear we can still see a level of
that with sky in the UK
um and with certain cable providers in
in various other markets but we think
that while this was an important factor
it is increasingly not so important
um
the the third angle is is pricing and uh
product differentiation so this is
something that uh is reconfirmed from
our first phase I'm not going to spend
too much time on this but obviously uh
prices for fiber need to be aggressive
compared to Legacy Solutions otherwise
it's very hard to uh to create drivers
but we also see that price is not enough
and product differentiation weighs a lot
in there as well
and typically uh one of the things that
we believe may be a market side issue is
that a lot of service providers are
still focused on offering a lot of
different packages over fiber starting
at speeds that are very comparable to
what might be found elsewhere and this
kind of dilutes the differentiation of
fiber compared to fttc or cable
um now I mentioned previously that we
couldn't find a data correlation between
digital literacy and uh and fiber
adoption now that doesn't mean that in
some markets we don't believe that
digital literacy is a hurdle uh as is
low income and two countries in
particular from our sample
um Poland where there's still a
significant portion of the country that
is not on the internet
at all entirely
uh and this is very much tied to rural
areas low-income digital literacy
um and also uh Italy where a significant
portion of the country is on Legacy ADSL
and does not seem to be uh easily
motivated to move to faster Broadband
speeds and again uh in the analysis that
we managed to do uh this was very much
tied to people not understanding how all
of this works and therefore are
concerned that any change is going to
create
um complications
so
not Universal but in certain specific
countries an important aspect now these
two aspects are very much about
awareness of Brands they're very
different but they actually act on the
same lever so what we see in markets
where uh a lot of the fiber products are
available through wholesale markets like
Italy or the UK right now
um
what we see in these markets is that the
absence of
National recognized brands on the fiber
platform or at least the Lesser weight
of these brands on the fiber platform uh
actually slows down adoption because a
lot of consumers would prefer to stay
with the trusted recognized National
brand that they already know
um similarly in some countries and this
is particularly uh the case in the UK
again uh in some countries
fiber advertising was not properly
regulated and basically anyone who was
selling any Broadband solution that had
even a tiny bit of fiber in it could
call it fiber and this is effectively
spoiled the fiber or terminology from a
marketing point of view which makes it
harder for
full fiber providers to actually
highlight the differences that this
contributes as an anecdote we heard from
a number of service providers in the UK
for example that when they call fttc
customers to offer a switch to fiber
these customers will tell them that they
already have fiber so the level of
misunderstanding is is quite High
now
um I've singled that Network competition
because it's both a very important
component and also one uh that
um is kind of evolving in an interesting
ways so
um if we look at markets where the
um fiber to home take up is the highest
a number of these markets have strong
Network competition so multiple service
providers uh competing to serve the same
customers sorry multiple Network
operators competing to serve the same
customers so this is obviously true in
Spain to a large extent it's true in
France as well at least in in a
significant portion of the population
coverage
um and there's no doubt that that
Dynamic was very positive in terms of
driving
um adoption now what's interesting
though is that as these markets mature
and we see this particularly in Spain we
see that there is a gradual shift from
Network competition to a wholesale model
where now in the Spanish Market most
operators actually uh
would rather go on someone else's
Network than deploy their own
and these are purely commercial basis
deals
um but so it so it's interesting and we
do think Network competition is a driver
but we also think that it is not
necessarily the only model that can
drive it option and you know the kind of
flip side of that is looking at Sweden
or Denmark where Network competition
historically was limited it's it's
increasing a little bit now uh in
Denmark at least but
um but we see that it's not the only
driver but it certainly is an important
driver
um now these two are connected to the
Legacy
copper Network for the most part I'm
going to start with the bottom one uh
which is firmly in the hands of policy
which is uh the ability to switch the
copper Network off now obviously this
driver only applies once uh once fiber
penetration and fiber adoption has
gotten to a stage where it is
envisageable to actually move forward
with copper switch off we're seeing this
now in Spain in France in Sweden uh and
and other countries have plans even
though it's probably a bit too early for
them
to execute on those plans
now obviously once consumers are told
that the copper network will no longer
exist down the line that creates a very
strong incentive for them to migrate
but interestingly what we're also
um
suspecting rather than seeing is would
be the right way of putting it I think
is that particularly with the energy
crisis that we're going through in
Europe right now
increased Opex of copper cable over
fiber because it's so much more hungry
from an energy standpoint
this will probably become a driver as
well for incumbent service providers at
least to accelerate their migrations
um but as I said we're not seeing this
just yet
all right the last three that I want to
talk about are around uh basically kind
of a combination of awareness and
availability so availability creates
awareness right so if you have fiber
available to 70 of the population uh a
lot a lot of people who were not aware
of this a few years ago even if they
were in fiber coverage areas become
aware of it and that creates a generic
public awareness but that can be
reinforced by you know local and
National governments in how they
communicate about uh availability of
infrastructure there's a a slightly
ironic thing that I heard from a from a
lot of
uh from a lot of uh players in in
various markets which is that local
governments uh go through a lot of
effort to get service providers to
um to connect the areas that they cover
that they that where their citizens live
um but once that's done they rarely
communicate about it so
um there's an element here that's that's
interesting and of course
with awareness uh comes word of mouth
and when word of mouth is positive which
it very often is with fiber once
installation is done
um then that creates a strong driver on
the market side
so this is really an overview and as I
said
um the detailed view for each country is
is available uh in the full study that
will be released today
but this is the conceptual framework
that we have used so from this uh we
also moved on to analyzing the few
existing demand side policies uh as I
said there are not a lot at least not in
the sense of a strongly pushed and
funded
um type of uh of demand side policies
basically there are two vouchers
programs that we could identify at
National level uh one in Italy and one
in Spain
um of course there are other aspects
like social tariffs but these are much
more spread about and and very hard to
uh assess the effectiveness of
we focused a lot of our analysis on the
Italian scheme because first of all it
was a lot more ambitious and also the
Spanish scheme is still underway so
there is no easy way to find
um you know analysis of of the
effectiveness in the Italian schemes
uh end users were subsidized to either
purchase new devices that could help
them connect or to uh get a new
subscription
um predominantly users went for better
devices
uh and this clearly did not drive
adoption of
better Broadband Solutions
the little impact that it had which from
memories around 20 percent of uh of
beneficiaries went for the subscriptions
uh and when they did they went for fdtc
and not ftth
so when we look at the amount of
subsidies that was uh that was put on
the table uh this was a very limited
impact in fact the program was put on
hold in order to reassess both the uh
allocation criteria and the subsidizing
models
um so there will be a new version of
this program which hopefully will be
more effective
um on the whole the the uh impression
that we got from all Market players
was that uh the schemes were not
effective and that there might be better
ways to spend that public money to drive
adoption
um but we will have to assess the new
versions of this when they come out
so
some key conclusions from from from all
of this the the
leading Common Thread is that when
countries decided countries and or
incumbents decided to focus on fttc
10 years ago or when cable has always
been a very strong player in that market
then adoption lags behind for ftth this
makes sense but it also means that now
that fttc is coming to a certain degree
to the end of its commercial life
um it's harder to shift the customers
over to the long-term solution that is
ftth
another factor that we see in markets
where wholesale is an important means to
access the market for service providers
is that the fragmentation of wholesale
platforms is a hurdle in other words if
you have 20 wholesale networks without a
common denominator for service providers
to serve all of them uh it makes it very
hard for uh the service providers to
serve the market and therefore it makes
it very hard for adoption on these
wholesale platforms to really uh
increase this is a very important issue
it's been solved in some markets uh like
France for example uh it's still a big
issue in other markets like the UK for
example
um now I mentioned that uh one of the
hurdles was the the the physical
connection itself and reluctance by
consumers at the time of subscription
um
this is clearly an issue that we see to
a larger or smaller extent in all
markets again some markets have
sometimes preemptively addressed this
like Spain for example where uh well in
in multi-tenant uh buildings uh vertical
ducts have been built for fiber or any
network in fact
um for the last uh 25 years which means
that this never really slowed down the
deployment
um in other markets like the UK uh this
is clearly an identified issue with with
um you know potentially strong consumer
resistance to the actual installation
um
so
as I said earlier we see that effective
Network competition has been a strong
driver uh other models have been
effective but these more wholesale
oriented models like we see in Sweden
and Denmark for example require that
strong National Brands be available on
fiber everywhere for them to be
effective so
um
to put it another way uh hold
predominant wholesale models without
participation of the national Brands uh
creates a situation where where take up
is
um damaged
and finally this is kind of more of an
overall uh
View and and kind of analysis of of the
entire scale of what we looked at uh the
impression that we got was that
basically uh markets where the the
the national plans for Broadband were
put in place early with strong
conceptual choices that were clearly
understandable by the market these
markets seem to be the ones that are the
most successful when it comes to take up
so typically uh you know uh Spain and
France uh
Sweden as well Denmark to a large extent
from early on it was quite clear where
the market was going this allowed uh
Market participants to invest with a
degree of confidence
um and it basically boosted both
deployment and adoption in other markets
like Germany or Italy or the UK where we
see a lot of uh fluctuation in what the
actual model is uh that seems to hamper
Market
um development
so
uh I wanted to spend a bit of time on uh
the
flip side of what policy can do right it
is absolutely evident to us that policy
can and should do a certain number of
things
to boost uh ftth or or in EU policy
parlance very high capacity Network vhgn
adoption but
we have also seen that some service
providers are not doing a very good job
at marketing their offers at
differentiating their pricing their
services their features their customer
experience at the moment of installation
might not be optimal
and those players that
get all of these things right absolutely
over perform the market
one clear example of this is for example
fibrous in the UK that has significantly
higher take-ups than a lot of the other
uh alt Nets and that is because they
understand what they're doing and
they're executing on it I think in ways
that are more effective than a lot of
other players in the market
um the other thing is that
uh there is this friction between
service providers and network operators
when wholesale is the key access to
Market and uh this friction this
hesitation from isps Etc this is
degrading the perceived value of fiber
by the consumers and this is an issue
that
very often the service providers have to
address amongst themselves one way or
another this may be an area for policy
to intervene when clearly the incumbent
is kind of
uh dragging its feet but otherwise it's
really something that the service
providers themselves
and the wholesale providers have to
figure out
um and finally uh
even though it's going away there are
still instances where service providers
are reluctant to reinvest in consumers
to get them over to fiber to home and
that reluctance basically uh keeps the
customer stuck on fttc or or other
Solutions that's also clearly uh in our
view a strategic error that is not for
policy to address but really for the
service providers themselves now
as I said policy has a role to play and
uh there are areas in which policy can
and should make a difference
uh the first one which I already
discussed is the switch off of pstn and
copper
this can only be fully implemented once
vht and adoption gets to 60 70 so
obviously not all countries in Europe
and and not even all countries in our
sample
but uh it is a very important driver and
it's important to understand that this
is also a key to a more sustainable
Telecom industry we hear a lot about
um service providers saying that they
need to be better at uh you know lower
carbon footprint Etc this will not
happen without the copper Network being
switched off so so that's something that
policymakers need to look into even if
the country is not at the stage where
they can execute on this yet
the second thing is even though the
voucher schemes that we've looked at
didn't seem to be very effective it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's a bad
idea but it needs to be implemented
better and targeted better in particular
there is a paradox in uh service
provider sorry in governments uh
encouraging and quite often funding
either through European funds or
National Funds the deployment of vhcn
networks and then not focusing their
demand side policies on adoption of vhn
networks why would I finance the
deployment of fiber with one hand and
then Finance the adoption of anything
with the other hand
these vouchers should be targeted at
driving vht and adoption which
incidentally is a European policy goal
so it's not just uh you know a nice to
have from a national regulator point of
view it is actually one of their 2030
goals
um the other thing is that the subsidies
are quite often focused on subscriptions
or devices but one of the things that
came clear particularly from the Italian
cases that maybe
that same funding could be used to
facilitate the migration in the same way
that for example with dtt schemes were
put in place where people would go to
meet older people people who had low
digital literacy to help them through
the process and basically make sure that
the migration was smooth this could very
well be done in rural areas uh among
pockets of elderly population uh and
might be a more effective way of using
these same funds that currently go to
voucher schemes
uh I already talked a lot about
wholesale fragmentation
one thing that policy makers can do uh
is to encourage uh National Brands maybe
brands with significant Market power to
participate in wholesale networks of a
of a you know big enough scale uh the
other angle is for maybe uh government
policy makers to get involved in
facilitating uh adoption of Industry
standards that eliminate a lot of the
Practical and I.T hurdles to serving
um wholesale Networks
um we talked about the advertising thing
earlier and uh clearly in some markets
the the
perception
of what fiber is and the benefits that
it delivers needs to be clarified
because of the choices that were made on
the advertising side
yeah it won't be a massive impact
ultimately because if that fiber brand
has been sullied then uh that's not
going to change now but it is important
then that
um that you know local governments in
particular be reactive when fiber gets
deployed in their area to actually
promote the benefits of fiber to their
citizens
um and that would be my last point I
think an area that is not necessarily
costly or complex for
governments to implement is simply to
uh basically connect their supply side
policy the further deployment of fiber
with demand side Clarity to say well
this is not just because we want the
infrastructure it is because we think
the citizens will benefit from it and
and that message very often is missing
so that's kind of the overview of the
study obviously
um the full document that you will be
able to access this afternoon has a lot
more detail
um but uh I hope I gave you a sense of
of where we got to and
um I'm very uh happy to take any
questions that you may have
well thank you very much Benoit I think
uh what you described is a relatively
complex situation with many stakeholder
involved multiple angle uh we we can use
to look at that question which remains
nevertheless extremely important and
that is kind of reflected in the
numerous question we get from the
audience I think that report is more the
the beginning of a conversation with all
stakeholder than than the final uh final
point to to these very important topic
so let me
um highlight some and ask the relay some
of the questions we received and thanks
everyone for sending this question on
the
on the app
um so first question is
um what about the availability of
Digital Services which Drive demand for
example but not only Netflix or other
content what about the the availability
of content as part of the the question
we are we are addressing
well as I mentioned
um a lot of the content now is available
to anyone who has uh a decent broadband
service so historically certain
providers had exclusive access to
certain contents that so if you wanted
Football League you had to be with
operator a or operator B this is
increasingly no longer true so while
uh the fact that there is more content
online is a driver for Broadband
adoption
um it is no longer a differentiator
um the last point to be made maybe is
that
um you know Netflix is actually very
effective at delivering high quality
video over a relatively limited amount
of bandwidth so even though
um
you know content in general can
absolutely Drive adoption of better
Broadband
um you can still experience very decent
uh quality content without having fiber
and and that means that it's going to be
one of many drivers rather than the sole
driver now having said that we did see
particularly during the various phases
of lockdowns that when you have three or
four people within the home using
Netflix at the same time to watch
different things that's when your fttc
connection is going to break down so it
does have an impact not the only impact
yeah have a question concerning in-home
connectivity indoor connectivity
solution
um question about you know is it is it
part of the equation is availability of
for example uh you know high quality
Wi-Fi or the lack of availability of
high quality Wi-Fi uh something
hindering the development of a fiber
adoption
again I wouldn't tie it specifically to
fiber what is clear is that from a
customer point of view from an end user
point of view most of them don't make a
difference between the Wi-Fi the
internet the fiber or the Broadband all
of this is one and the same
um so uh having uh low quality Wi-Fi
with a high quality connection uh is
something that the service provider
might be aware is the issue the customer
might not so in that sense yes it can be
a hurdle
but it's not necessarily
something that affects fiber only it
affects all solutions now obviously if
you can tie as part of your offering and
this is what connects me back to
differentiation if you can tie you know
really good in-home connectivity
solutions to your fiber product then you
will drive an option of the fiber
product but the issue is not related to
fiber directly
okay I have another question which
relates to
um the business benefits of fiber in
term of lower carbon footprint compared
to Alternative Access Network Technology
and how does the you know European
Target around our environment play into
helping
um fiber yeah dry fiber adoption
basically
well
um it it
absolutely needs to be aligned right
there is no way that we get to a more
sustainable industry without more fiber
and less
copper and likely less cable because
cable is very
uh energy hungry
having said that
um I don't think this is a consumer
issue in other words
it is for the service providers and
particularly the incumbent service
providers to realize that they need to
accelerate fiber adoption
uh for this to truly happen and if
they're not very good at marketing their
own fiber Services then that's going to
be slower than they intend so we're kind
of as you said it's a complex issue with
multiple factors but clearly I thought
that we would already hear people saying
we need to do this we need to accelerate
this and maybe even governments saying
we need to impose some Targets on energy
consumption of network operators to
accelerate this
it's not the case yet and I think the
reason is that
the key driver is actually Financial
rather than uh rather than green at this
point in time in other words when it
hurts financially that's when things are
going to accelerate it so happens that
it's going to be greener but I sadly
don't think that the primary motivation
at this point in time
is the uh the kind of eco-consciousness
angle
I have a question which uh strangely
come to us via email
related to the relative
hurdle which are linked to the category
of network that consumer needs to
migrate from in other words is it easier
to migrate A customer from
copper to fiber than it is from hfc
Network to fiber have we measured that
do we have any element to
um
to describe the maybe the difference in
in those two scenarios
well so so we could be talking about two
different things here one which is the
technical difficulty and one which is
from a marketing point of view it's more
the question is more around marketing
how do you okay is it more difficult to
convince someone currently
um being on a coax to migrate to fiber
than it is to convince someone currently
on Legacy copper to move to fiber
theoretically yes in the same way that
it's harder to get someone to come from
fttc to ftth than it is to come from
ADSL to ftth uh that would be the same
kind of lever
that said a lot of cable operators in
Europe for a variety of reasons have
relatively low
customer confidence customer Trust
the brands in other words are often
quite fragile and when that is the case
then it's not a matter of performance
what is going to get the customer to
migrate to another solution is just the
fact that he's going to have another
provider
so I think there is a marketing angle to
play on the weakness of certain cable
brands in certain markets
um but that means that you need to
deliver a better product and at a
cheaper price anyway so you know it's a
reinforcement of product differentiation
uh it's not enough on its own and also
you need to have a brand that's
perceived as you know better or more
positive Etc
I have a question related to one of the
point you you mentioned
um and this is
um
what about the the price gap between uh
ftth and cable because the the person
mentioned that you refer to price gap
between copper and fiber
um Sam does the same point applied to
the price difference between cable and
coax cable and fiber
well then we get into a specific
difficulty of of pricing comparisons
which is that
cable still to this day is usually
packaged with a lot of content
um Telecom operator is increasingly
either don't include a lot of content or
do it in a way that's very cheap and and
is more like repackaging national uh you
know
um
terrestrial uh channels and stuff like
that so
um it's hard to compare the prices but
we see in in other markets where this
price Gap is higher that
if cable keeps on packaging a lot of
content it's very hard for them to get
to a price point where they are actually
competing with ftth now if you're in the
ftth market and you're offering
something that's more expensive than
cable I would immediately say that
that's probably not the right strategy
um but my point is if we're looking at
cable as being Broadband plus TV and
compare that to ftth as being Broadband
it's not a it's not a valid comparison
basis but as I said as as ownership of
content and exclusivity of content
becomes less and less of a relevant
issue that's going to make it harder and
harder for cable to compete on that
basis and we do see actually some cable
operators like virgin in the UK and I
think they go in the Netherlands as well
um
that are you know increasingly going
Broadband only so that they can compete
with Broadband only on the other side
okay all right I've got still quite a
lot of questions I will not be able to
address all of them try to bundle three
of them which are related to the the
relation between overbuilt and Tech up
have we seen a negative or positive
correlation between the level of
overbuilt and the the adoption of fiber
okay so this is actually a data issue
which means that I can't conclusively
give an answer to this
um even at a regulator level there is
very little data on overbuilding that is
publicly available so in markets like
Spain and France for example you do not
know exactly
who connects how many homes and how many
of those are competing with other homes
so this makes it hard to analyze this in
a in a rational way there is like
anecdotal evidence that Network
competition drives adoption but that
doesn't mean that overbuild in itself uh
is the primary factor there's also a
very real question of is the third
overbuilder still benefiting from from
an impact or or does have a positive
impact or is it only the second one I
can't really I don't know I can't answer
these questions unfortunately okay
well I think but while we're getting to
towards the end of the session I know
many of you on the call probably have a
hot stop at the top of the hour moving
to to another meeting so I don't want to
uh delay anyone
um as I said we will go through the
unanswered question and probably go back
to uh to to to those who who send these
remarks
um as you say uh the full report or
maybe uh
probably a way to cover most of the
question which went to us and is now
available on our website it will also be
shared with the thank you ml which will
be sent to to all participants
um the ftth council is providing you
with more than just this report there
are many uh element from a technology
and Market standpoint you can find uh on
our website we also encourage you to to
join us in Madrid for the ftth
conference where a session will be
dedicated to this topic and actually
it's likely to be a point whereas in
multiple panel and workshop at the
conference
so with that I would like to thank again
Benoit for his hard work on this report
for this presentation today for
answering uh
with a lot of knowledge to all questions
um and I would like to thank our
audience you've been very consistent uh
throughout the the one hour so showing
your interest in the topic so thanks
again have a good rest of your day and I
would be very happy to see you on one of
our future events thank you
thank you